oh would you rather fall into a pit of
snakes or a pit of spiders oh i hate
both bubbles oh spiders
[Music]
would you rather spend the night in a
haunted house or in a cemetery
oh different answers
why i'm scared of cemeteries i'm not
scared of somebody
would you rather fight frankenstein or
the mummy frankenstein the
mommy why
i don't like mummies i could unwrap the
money as fast all i gotta do is grab him
and spin his around he did would you
rather be a vampire or a ghost ghost
ghost ghost why ghosts i like ghosts we
can get away from everything but i'm a
vampire so well you can't come out today
you can't come out in the daytime you
have to be white and miserable
[Laughter]
would you rather be attacked by crows or
by bats bats crows
why bats because they don't pick your
eyes out pros i can fight them off and i
keep some you know sunflower seeds and
some corn on me to keep them off my back
oh this is a good one what was the first
fear you conquered scared of the dark
how did you conquer it my mama made me
sleep in a room by myself one night and
i had to conquer it fear of
falling from great heights
oh how did you conquer that i
jumped off a very tall
cliff hopefully into water oh yes oh
i was about to say you still live to
tell the tale first halloween costume
you chose for yourself little bo peep
that's a good one mine's probably uh
bruce lee oh bruce lee yeah i didn't
have no money for a costume so i just
tied a
little white robe around me put the
black belt on it and i was bruce lee
what was the first prank you ever pulled
ding dong ditcher that's when we used to
go knock on doors and then run fast
one very effective one was leaning down
to pick something up from the floor and
coming up with blood dripping all over
my face
and it was just red food coloring yeah i
know you scared everybody in your family
very scary god
that is very different than ding dong
ditch yeah i'm saying right she's on the
edge oh what was the first untrue rumor
you heard about yourself that i was a
bad guy
okay because i'm really a good guy that
i was a bad girl but and i was always a
good girl
what's your biggest fear it's not being
able to make people smile i'm not afraid
of anything doesn't she look fearless
she looks fearless she's a survivor what
kind of party do you want to throw next
at the tasty mansion i probably want to
throw a christmas party next christmas
yeah man ain't nothing like christmas
man they're not like having your family
and giving away gifts and you're
celebrating the whole year in review and
martha just you know she loves to give
people very well so i'm just saying that
so i get some free gifts from marketing
okay i remember that
buzzfeed taste buds what it does it's
your homeboy snoop deal dub and the
place to be oh we and i'm martha stewart
for buzzfeed tasty and don't forget to
watch snoop and martha's very tasty
halloween on
peacock yeah
p-1014 which translates to october 14.
bring some candy some bakeries we're
going to wake and bake you understand me
you'll be surprised you'll be terrified
you'll be
just nullified by snoop and martha and a
special guest
not alvin from the chipmunks
put my nephew out
yes sir
[Music]
you